j'ai ramé claude voulons parfaitement
expliqué il n'y a pas de construction et
pourtant il y avait des possibilités de
construire et chez nathalie nous avons
porté en effet ensemble le projet des
projets d'envergure comme la couverture
partielle du périphérique qui aurait
permis justement gagné du foncier mais
aussi la couverture par exemple de bercy
charenton où dix mille logements sont
possibles sur cette zone
et là encore la mairie n'a pas
d'envergure sur ses projets ayrault se
refuse surtout de travailler avec le
secteur privé ce qui aurait permis
notamment charpié arrive dans le xviiie
dossier construire à la porte de la
chapelle
je voulais insister sur la faible
rotation dans le parc du logement social
c'est un des échecs aussi majeur de la
politique de la ville en effet vous avez
un taux de 3% de rotation dans le
logement social de la ville et rien
n'est fait je dis bien rien n'est fait
pour gérer ce qu'on appelle le parcours
résidentiel des locataires c'est à dire
que la ville de paris ne se préoccupe
pas d'évolution des familles que ce soit
de leur taille que ce soit de leurs
ressources financières ou encore
simplement de leurs aspirations
nous en tant qu'élus nous connaissons
des dizaines et dizaines de dossiers où
nous pouvons nous voulons échanger une
famille qui vit serré dans un f1 est au
contraire des personnes âgées qui vit
dans un f4 mais les changes ne se fait
pas et en effet il existe il existe des
solutions
c'est un accompagnement personnalisé à
la sortie du logement social c'est aussi
le maintien du prix au mètre carré pour
la classe moyenne et aussi comme l'ont
en effet développé claude et girum c'est
l'accession à la propriété
c'est un mot tabou au niveau de la
mairie de paris rien n'est fait à ce
sujet dans le 12e arrondissement vous
avez la caserne de rully qui par exemple
400 logements vont être créées 0 en
accession à la propriété et en effet ça
fait partie d'un des piliers majeurs du
programme de valérie pécresse de
pierre-jean vazel faire en sorte que la
propri l'accession à la propriété soit
accessible à une majorité de parisiens
et notamment la classe moyenne alors que
le joola dit en effet il y a simplement
de la communication et je voulais finir
par deux exemples très significatif de
la communication vous l'envoyez
régulièrement par monsieur ian brossât
qui nous explique que la classe moyenne
va être aidé que les jeunes activant
être aidés mais quand on est en conseil
de paris
je peux vous dire que chaque fois que à
chaque programme de logements neufs nous
proposons qu'il y ait un logement
intermédiaire ou simplement une part de
pl
c'est plus importante tous nos voeux et
nos amendements sont rejetés d'un seul
trait et encore une illustration de
cette politique de communication
monsieur ian brossât ya pas très
longtemps a annoncé que les commissions
d'attribution lettre ouverte à tous les
parisiens mais sachez que nous en tant
qu'aide à deux parisiens mais qui
s'avère être ouvert aux parisiens
sachez que ça avait plus qu un an et
demi que nous demandons nous élus de
l'opposition qui sommes quand même les
représentants du peuple
nous demandons à siéger dans une
commission qui s'appelle comité
intérieur où justement sont débattus
l'accession et la rotation des logements
sociaux
nous n'arrivons pas à siéger dans cette
commission dans ce comité
alors qu'une somme élu de la république
et représentants du peuple ça vous
montre bien le décalage entre les
paroles et entre les actes en guise de
conclusion je voulais juste vous dire
que la politique du logement à paris en
effet est une farce c'est une grande
tromperie et que hélas ce sont les 180
mille demandeurs de logements sociaux ce
sont les classes moyennes qui en payent
le prix est la seule façon de basculer
cette tragédie
c'est en effet de soutenir valérie
pécresse et piriot bournazel pour
améliorer la politique du logement
je vous remercie